[Music]
well this year halloween falls on a
weekend so no doubt there's going to be
plenty of parties the national retail
federation expects consumers to spend
more than 10 billion dollars on
halloween related items that's a new
record and while the cdc encouraged us
to stay home last year this time it's
given us the green light to safely
trick-or-treat in small groups madison
kimbrough is live in front of a spirits
halloween store with more on the outlook
for the season madison
more people are expected to celebrate
halloween this year with all the events
happening across the valley but for
businesses it is their chance to make up
for what was lost last year
for parents like mark ackfully and kerry
wilson halloween can't come soon enough
she wants to be pennywise and he wants
to be a marshmallow man kind of like the
michelin man we love halloween want to
kind of go back to normal and let the
kids have fun martin sadowitz would like
to see things back to normal too he owns
the american costume store on sahara
stocking shelves has been a struggle so
many costume companies have gone out of
business it is so difficult
to be in this time period
with the covet crisis
and try to supply people with costumes
yeah sales have gone down
almost about half as for haunted houses
rich stralak the owner of asylum and
hotel fear is excited to see people
return and is still looking for
volunteer actors i think we're still
going to have a good audience coming out
this year because people
they're always going to be hesitant but
we'll still do volunteers up throughout
the season if we can work them in as for
the number of people allowed in the
haunted house it's a max of six at a
time and reservations can be made online
now as for the shoppers here at spirit
most said they had no problem finding
the costume or decorations they wanted
although at one location we went to at
spirit they said they were sold out of
the talking chucky doll reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now